what is going on everybody and welcome
to a video on
auto encoders so auto encoders are
neural networks that are trained
to encode and subsequently decode
um input information so by encoding
what we mean is generally compressing it
or denoising it
or just reducing it to fewer
fewer information than the input ideally
it doesn't have to be
that way so another form of encoding
might just be we want to change
the the format of the data but generally
it's going to include some sort of
shrinking of the size you would not use
an
auto encoder at least i haven't seen any
for actually the purpose of like video
compression let's say you would probably
want to use some sort of mathematical
proven formula for this but instead
auto encoders are very popularly used
with more
of your advanced and complex problems
with
machine learning and deep learning i
think the best way to
understand stuff like this is just to do
it so let's go ahead and jump in and
learn a little bit
about uh about auto encoders so
uh the first order of business is that
we get ourselves
some data so we're gonna import
tensorflow
as tf we're going to from tensorflow
we're going to import keras
we're going to import um i can think i
think matplotlib.piplot as plt
we could also use cb2 for visualization
there will be text-based version there
is a text-based version of this tutorial
i will put a link in the description
uh in that we're i'm going to use opencv
instead because you can very quickly
like cycle through things but
i always have problems on various it's
like the way that you handle it is
different on
each operating system i know matplotlib
will act the same way that i'm used to
so i'm going to use matplotlib here
we're also going to
uh we probably see i think i'll still
use cv2 probably
in this tutorial to resize things so i
will still import it and then we'll
import
uh numpy as np
so to begin we are going to specify
the x train y train yeah
x train y train and then x
test y test even though we don't
actually need that information and we're
going to use the
mnist data set uh the reason why we're
going to use it is
honestly the data set doesn't really
matter that much if you have your own
we're going to be working with images so
if you've got your own images and
especially if you just want to like
grayscale those images real quick
feel free to pause it and use something
else you don't have to use this data set
but that's what we're going use uh for
this tutorial so
[Music]
tf.karas.datasets.mnist.load
so what we have here uh if you're not
familiar we can just show plt.show
and we'll show x train zero
and actually a couple things first of
all we'll say cmap gray
and it's not show it's m show
if we want to show an image so once we
get the import
uh load is it like load oh it's load
underscore
data so load data
like so okay
cool so here we have like a five
for example we could check another data
point a zero
and so on so they're just handwritten
digits uh and some
more further information uh x train
say zero dot shape uh it's they're 28 by
28
and as you can see they're gray scale
and also if it was more
if it was like rgb it would be 28 by 28
by three for example
so in this case it's 28 by 28 data and
if we just run the numbers
real quick we see that 28 by 28 is 784
so when you feed this through a neural
network that is
784 unique features if it was
rgb it would be multiplied by three and
now you would have actually 2
352 features this is an rgb but in the
future
we hopefully at the end i'll show an
example of rgb because
certain things change with the
autoencoder but we'll get there
so anyway in this case it's 28 by 28 784
features which
is a lot of features so um
luckily the endness dataset's actually a
really easy one for neural networks to
learn and we can talk a little bit about
why that might be but
um it's a very easy one but for neural
networks
784 input features can often be very
challenging so the idea of compressing
those features
down in such a way that it would make
learning for the neural network easier
that's always good
and then if you've got features that are
noisy i.e kind of useless features
why not toss those out so this is us
using a neural network to hopefully
figure out these things so in a lot of
cases for example maybe the features are
all useful
but certain features um have
relationships with each other
such that uh maybe you've got five
features but you could actually because
of the way that they
interact with each other five features
could actually be condensed into
two or three features and then imagine
that uh
spread across hundreds of features if
you're able to do something like that
you can simplify the problem and with
neural networks
if you're having a hard time getting a
neural network to learn something
the the first thing you should always be
thinking of is
how can we make this an easier problem
for the neural network to learn
and when a neural network is training
it's trying to do kind of two things at
one time right it's trying to
figure out what is this data what are
the relationships between these features
and it's trying to do say classification
so it's doing it's kind of doing two
things at once and the idea of an
autoencoder
as you'll soon see the input is the
output so it's actually just mapping the
input to the output and the idea is to
have some sort of bottleneck along the
way
and doing that hopefully makes it easier
for the network to learn so so we know
we have 784
uh features now with all image data uh
the like right now uh let's just print
out x train zero
we can see the values are everything
from zero to
there's probably i don't see a 255 i see
a bunch of 253s but i assure you
it goes to 255. uh anyway the data is
zero to 255. so generally one of the
things that were
we do with image data is just divide by
255 including if it's rgb so
we're going to say x train equals x
train divided by 255 you could also say
something like x test div
was it div equals 255 i think either of
those should work
so we'll do that can we not get away
with doing that
div equals i thought we could do div
equals i guess not um i'm sure what i do
why that wouldn't work x test div
255 okay
anyway i'm sure maybe that was really
obvious i don't know anyway
so now we have our data and so just just
to
show it real quick um
it's kind of ugly but i assure you these
are all of these values are now between
0 and 1
instead of 0 to 255 and again for neural
networks
we generally like to keep data between
negative 1 and positive 1 or 0 and 1. so
in this case it's between zero and one
so okay so we have our data we've
pre-processed our data
how we'd like uh but the problem again
is it's 784 features
so what we're going to try to do is
condense those down so we're going to
start by defining
um our basically an autoencoder is going
to consist of
two models into one model so we're going
to have an encoder
and we're going to have a decoder so
we're going to say encoder underscore
input and this is going to be a keras
dot
input layer and the shape is
going to be oops it's actually shape
uh it will be a 28 by 28 28 by 28
and then one and again if this one is
this is how many channels is it
so if it was rgb you would put a three
there instead and then we'll give it a
name
and we'll just say uh image for now
so that's the input to our neural
network um now what we want to do
is attempt to condense it so
in our case with the mnist data set it
is gray scale so we don't have these
three channels to work with
it's pretty simple data we don't have to
use any convolutional layers
now this will allow us to simplify and
for me to show you
like how this works also a lot of
problems that use auto encoders
aren't doing it on image data at all
like you don't have to do this on image
data the only reason we're doing it on
image data
is to um because you can actually
visualize what the
autoencoder does which i think is really
cool so
so we're not going to use any
convolutional layers and then if you do
use convolutional layers
it adds a slight degree of complexity
but again
at the end of this tutorial i will show
you some code that that
does use convolutional layers including
pooling and all this kind of stuff
because that makes it a little more
challenging but for now we'll keep it
nice and simple
and we're just going to use dense layers
and to begin we are going to flatten
that so
keras.layers.flatten
and we're going to do that to the
encoder input layer um
so as opposed so i think i want i want
to say this is like keras functional as
opposed to using the sequential
type of model you can do like the model
dot add if you want and just add a
flattened layer
and so on um i haven't really decided
which one i like i've started kind of
using this one instead i almost think
this makes more sense um
i don't know anyway just take note
because i think this might be the first
time i've used this on the channel
so uh so we have a flattened layer so
again
that's going to flatten all of the input
to be basically 784
so then we can have just a dense layer
so we'll just say
x equals karas.layers dot
dense and we'll go with
64 and this will get multiplied by the
you know this x here so we have that
dense layer
uh oh we need to do activation equals
rectified linear and um
honestly that's probably all we need uh
for our encoder
uh so i think what we'll do is
yeah we'll just call this rather than x
we'll say encoder
encounter encoder
underscore out and that will be equal to
chaos.layers.dense
and that's probably all we need more
complex information might require a more
complicated encoder
but often it's the case that you don't
need more than this and again because
the the problem that we're trying to
solve here is actually the easier of
the many problems that neural networks
have to solve
and again the benefit of using an auto
encoder is it's kind of
um it's it's that sort of separation
of tasks right the auto encoder's only
task
is to solve this sort of condensation
problem so so that's our encoder
and in case we want to use the encoder
later you could do this where for both
we're just we're actually only going to
show the encoder layer
later i mean but for now we'll say
encoder and that's going to be equal to
a keras.model
and that's going to be everything from
the encoder input
to the encoder and i kind of want to
make this to be output
out put
and uh we'll give it the name
name i'll call encoder
so now we have our encoder now we need
our decoder so again
the autoencoder is going to take input
and map it
literally to the exact same input so the
only constraint that we have with an
auto encoder
is that the output like layer is
exact as an exact match to the input so
in this case
it's a it needs to match 28 by 28 by one
so uh the way that we're going to do
that is first of all
we could we could probably just go
straight to the output but we'll go
ahead and uh
we'll have we'll have a dense layer
first so you could
there's a couple of things there's a
couple of ways we could do this but i
think probably
we're just going to throw in a dense
layer so here's what we'll do we'll say
x equals uh keras.layers
and we'll say 784 we know that we need
to end on 784 values at some point so
we'll just throw in 784 a 784
dense layer shouldn't be too complicated
for us to use anyways
so activation equals uh
rectified linear and
uh this gets multiplied by your
encoder and then finally so we have 784
we know 784 is the result of 28 by 28.
how do we get this back to be 28 by
28 like we need that to to go back
alternatively
you there's a million ways you can do
this you could and it might be quicker
using maybe numpy even first i haven't
actually tested this but
uh you could also just prior to feeding
it through the neural network
we could have actually flattened our
data and then it would already be 784
and you could actually end on 784
probably
um but we're going to do we'll we'll
keep it this way especially because
eventually if you use like rgb data with
like three channels then it becomes
so way more taxing i think to flatten it
prior
anyway uh so we'll do it this way dents
and
the big takeaway i think i hope is that
there's like a million ways that you
could
you can make an auto encoder literally
the only thing that matters
is that you map input to input that's it
so uh keras layers then 784 and then
we'll have
our um and actually let me think about
this
uh this really should be
uh let's see so dance
i think probably so we've we've defined
our encoder
and this could be our decoder let's see
decoder
uh input could just be this like dense
layer
uh we also you could start with a 64.
i don't actually think a lot of times
you're going to see the decoder is
almost an exact mirror representation of
the encoder
it's probably not necessary in this case
so i'm actually just gonna leave it like
that
and then we'll say if it doesn't work
i'll fix it but uh we're gonna say
decoder
underscore output all we have to do here
is keras.layers.reshape
and again what is the shape that we need
this to be it's the exact
shape from that input right so 28
28 1 and then
that is multiplied by uh decoder
input and that is
our decoder right all we needed it to do
is to just decode out
to um 784
basically and then reshape it to 28 by
28 and now it
is an exact match of the input so
now all we need to do is we're going to
specify an optimizer that's going to be
tf.keras and in fact i don't even think
we need to say tf.keras because we're
using keras already so we'll just say
keras
dot optimizers dot atom
we're gonna specify our learning rate of
zero zero one
uh for this problem we don't actually
really need a decay but we'll just throw
one in there anyways um
okay we've got our optimizer now we're
going to specify our auto encoder
uh model and again this is like our
encoder model it's just going to contain
everything from
in fact i'll take this copy paste
everything from encoder input to decoder
output and we'll just call this auto
encoder
and then finally let's do
autoencoder.summary and let's make sure
that we haven't made any mistakes
i need to delete this so i don't have to
see this anymore let's just do that
train
activation oh encoder
uh it needs to be encoder output not the
encoder model
okay that was quick okay so as we can
see it does indeed
um end on the exact same obviously like
for example our reshape would fail
if we used anything other than 784 here
so again what what is a dense layer
right a dense layer
is going to produce literally just a
vector of 700 in this case
784 values and then all we're doing is
just
we're just gonna have that whatever the
output of those 784 neurons is
we reshape it to a 28 by 28 by one and
then boom we start optimizing
calculating loss all that fun stuff
so um okay so i think we're actually
uh good to start training um so
let's see i'm trying to decide i kind of
already know
how many epochs is required i kind of in
the text based version of the tutorial i
did like a little loop
um only because i didn't actually know
how many it would take but in this case
i think we can just do
auto encoder dot fit
and in this case it is x
train x train so again this is your x
this is your y
in the case of an auto encoder you're
literally mapping x to x you're mapping
features to features and the whole
point of all of this is to
hopefully go from 784 features
down to 64 features
and then we can prove that it works by
then d
um decoding it from these 64
features again that's 64 features that's
just a vector of 64 values
uh we're decompressed basically to 784
and then we reshape it
if this does work what does this tell us
right it tells us that
rather than feeding through like we have
this auto encoder
so we've trained this encoder to take an
image of 784 values
and condense it down to 64 values yet
still contain the same meaning
and then what we could do is we could
before we pass data through
a different neural network if our if our
training data
are these mnist images rather than
feeding through
the 784 samples we could actually feed
through the encoded
64 samples thus making the problem
easier on the model to learn also we can
change the data types
and more on that later but first let's
make sure this works
so we fit x to x x train x train
uh let's see if there's anything else
apox equals three
and then batch size probably 32 will be
good enough
and then validation split
spull it equals 0.1
okay um let's see if that works no
oh we didn't compile the model dummy uh
let's go ahead and let's get that done
huh
so we'll do autoencoder dot compile
where did we define
the optimizer i got so busy with the
summary uh we did get the optimizer in
there so compile
uh and then we'll just say opt and loss
equals we'll go with mean squared error
let's try that one more time
okay the model is training and now what
we want to do
uh while we let that go for one more
epoch is basically we're going to now
take our x test data so we train this
model on the training data so it was
basically x train to x train samples now
we're going to start referencing the x
test and the first order of business
will be to come down here
looks like everything is done we now we
have the
auto encoder that's trained but that
also means we have our
encoder trained up here so
i can come down here and what we can say
is we can basically just say example
equals uh whoops encoder
dot predict and again um
predictions i say again because i've had
to say this like every tutorial
predict takes a list of predictions even
if you only have one prediction and
it outputs a list of predictions even if
it was only one
so i'm going to end with zero and in the
list we're gonna go with x
test we'll go with zero um
and we can print
example oh we didn't let's see i think
we have two yeah we gotta reshape it
uh moments of truth and just ruined
reshape
uh and what is it negative 1 28 28 1. so
again
again it's taking a list and in this
case it only has one value
so we're just going to reshape it
essentially to be this unknown
size which happens to be one by 28 by 28
by one
try again cool so now we have this is
the
um the encoded uh
version and as you can see here if we do
example dot
shape it's 64 values so we went from 784
down to 64
which is 784 about eight percent
of the original size uh we can also
visualize this to
some extent if we did something like plt
dot m show now again this is not meant
to be an image
um so take this with a grain of salt but
example dot
uh can't type today
uh since it's 64 we can reshape it to an
eight
by eight i want more space i don't like
staring down there we go uh m show
example uh and then c map
wow i just i can't type today i don't
know great
okay so this is our uh condensed
version and as you can see we actually
have kind of a lot of
what i would suggest are actually still
useless pixels but that's kind of
interesting
um let's see what the
actual encoder uh said so oh and
also let's go ahead and plt dot m show
the uh let's see test
what did we do zero actually it's x test
i think x test zero
uh and then again c map equals
[Music]
gray i'm actually kind of worried that
uh i'm not sure this will translate
we're gonna find out um so the way that
we find out is by actually doing an auto
encoder
so we'll do this time we see we will say
ae out equals
autoencoder dot fit and actually we'll
do really the exact same thing that we
did
up here or dot fit dot predict
so we'll scroll down dot predict
so we have the prediction and then what
we would do
is we don't want to actually run the
reshape
so we'll just do plt.m show the ae
out
boom and no that did not work
fascinating i almost wonder if
uh we do need that um
that extra layer i'm actually kind of
interested if that is truly what is
necessary
i did i really did not think that we
were gonna need that input
uh let's see so we went straight from
784 to the reshape
and the way i initially did this was
essentially had one more
so the input was actually 64.
64.
and then it went to 780 784 we'll say
x here
x here and then this would be decoder
input here
let me make sure that's exactly what i
had otherwise that should
i mean that should be the same i'm going
to be super
let's see what happens
i really didn't think that extra 64 unit
layer would do anything
so now i'm concerned there might be some
other issue but yeah
dang there's something else going on
here what is it
let's see flatten dense rectified linear
almost going to have to i think
maybe i'll copy the uh the original and
just see if we
get the exact same what else would this
could this be x train
[Music]
unless did we
possibly run
let's do this
part of me wonders because we might have
run that div by 255
twice that could be part of the problem
i don't work in notebooks often enough
that uh i think i might have run the div
by 255
two times and that might have caused it
but i'm not sure
yeah i think that's what it was
that's interesting so
in case you didn't follow my guess
is what caused the problem was when i
did this div equals
uh here in this cell uh what did we do
it on i think we must
i think we so basically what we did was
for the training data
we did by 255 and then this errored out
and then i div by 255 again
i'm gonna i'm gonna wager that's exactly
what happened
i'm not sure uh i kind of wanna oh i
really wanna find out if that's what it
was
so uh because that would make sense
uh so if we just ran this one more time
and then we do all this again
sorry to waste everybody's time but i'm
actually super curious
so if this doesn't work especially if it
shows all those like dead pixels
that would also explain why so many of
those pixels were like kind of dead
yeah yeah interesting
okay um so let me let me go ahead and
unscrew this up where was the uh
where was the div that's what i get for
like i never work in notebooks it just
makes sense for me to be working in a
notebook for like this tutorial
and that bit me in the in the butt
did i get it cool okay so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to restart
kernel and run all cells hopefully we
don't run into that
that again oh but actually so now i want
to go back
because i kind of want a next one
uh okay so actually i want to say
decoder input
and then it goes uh oh let's see um so i
want that to be commented out i want
this to be back to decoder input
and i want this to be 784
still working uh restart
kernel and run all cells uh okay
because i want to make i want to see if
this actually works like it should it
should work
uh to just go straight to 784 one dense
layer that's more than enough to learn
this data
and then we can get back to the uh get
back to the tutorial now
so um you've already seen that it
actually does work
uh looks like that worked cool so yeah
so
uh so this was the original input data
and then this is the output i mean and
we can test we could do a couple other
ones so let's say we want to go with one
okay it's a two we'll throw in a one
here again
and it's a two and uh and in fact we can
come up here
uh example we need to streamline this
for sure
but we'll do this
so this is our condensed two um
and yeah so you can see that this uh
definitely worked
and i think i think i'll
probably i think we'll make our change
first and then and then i'll change some
of this code but what's important to
recognize again
is we went from 784 features down to
this many features uh 64. uh
and then we decoded so we encoded down
to 64 features and then back
up to 784 to essentially reproduce the
the number that was the input it's a
little dimmer
it's not it's not a perfect replication
and that's why
uh it it's not like this would be a
great method
for again doing like video compression
on a website
youtube is probably not using auto
encoders um
so so um again the the point
is for um features condensing features
down and it's doing so in an
unsupervised machine learning way
in that as you can kind of already see
here this this
two and this two are slightly different
they're not
exactly the same so um i think to make
this even more clear
we can take this down quite a bit so
we've got 64 here
could we condense that down to 32
so i will go ahead and do that and in
fact
[Music]
i am going to condense
this code actually i want to cut that
paste that so we will run
that i'm going to get rid of that
we have our example information i don't
know that we
need to have the shape but we'll go
ahead and print
uh example.shape as well
um this one what do we go with do we say
32 this time yeah so we're bottlenecking
to 32 samples only
so again 32 uh print let's say 32 out of
784
uh so this is basically condensed down
to four percent
uh we can print uh example
uh rather than reshaping to eight by
eight uh
32 yikes uh we don't really have a great
i guess eight by
four right yeah that's i guess away
again these image representations are
just so we can see the values that
that's not actually meant to be an image
because actually this right here at the
output from our example is the output
from our encoder and what is that it's
actually just a dense layer output it's
just a vector of values
period so we just happen to reshape it
and make a pretty image out of it but
that's it
so okay so we get rid of this
we can
keep that i'm gonna get rid of this and
the original
cut paste so this was a two are we again
using test.1 yes
variables would help a ton
and then we will paste this here
so that's ae out and then we'll go ahead
and do the
m show right away so now let me just do
this real quick
and i think we'll just delete these okay
so again it worked we have a couple of
like dead pixels here
uh but for the most part it looks like
everything is working
you know pretty well so again we can go
with x test three for example we can
change this
[Applause]
let me go ahead and actually run this
one run this one
run that one okay hopefully it's going
to be a zero
xs3 and there we go so we have a zero
again and
and again it has a lot of the original
features like there's like a little
extra bit
up here on the zero it has that too and
it does
it's still missing some value here it is
slightly dimmer
but it's very clearly a zero and you
know we can keep going
and just see like how how tiny can we
get this so
um let's go let's do a nine so like a
three by three essentially
so we will retrain that um
and let's just rerun essentially
everything here
i won't we don't necessarily unless we
see anything like super interesting
um i won't reiterate through a bunch of
different samples but you should get the
idea here
um whoops uh this should be a
three by three so okay
so this information does it contain a
zero
and it does it's not the best zero it's
not the most beautiful zero that we've
ever seen
but it is a zero and to me i think this
is super cool
that we condensed 784 values
into nine a vector of nine values
and it did a pretty good job
it's still very clearly a zero uh let's
go back
to what was the five was it zero i think
oh no i guess that was a seven
oh so let's show that one real quick
let's make sure okay so these are
two clear these are clearly both sevens
but this is like a this is not the same
seven so
what's happened here is we definitely
have a neural network
that has just learned okay this data is
a seven so in code
seven but it's not the exact same seven
because again we've come down to
literally only nine values
which i'm sorry i just find that
fascinating i cannot i know mnist is
easy
but if anything this should show you how
easy of a problem mnist is to solve
because we literally condense down to
nine values and we're able to produce
this
um
that's insane that's just insane
so okay so that is
auto encoders uh we can show
i think i'll show one more interesting
aspect of the auto encoder but again
so like imagine you're the auto encoder
uh how might you
condense this information well you know
really quickly with the mnis data set
one thing you could do is chop away
all corners right like this corner here
this corner here
this corner here in this corner here
they're almost always dead information
right there's no information there
right so so immediately you could
probably chop
this data down fairly considerably but i
don't know about you but there is no way
i could condense it down to be
nine values i just think that's crazy
it's just crazy uh let's and
let again we can we can visualize those
exam those values
uh print example these are the values
right
that's cool i just think that's super
cool um
okay so all right so we've made it this
far uh the next thing i want to show
i don't think there's really any benefit
in me coding this
uh i want to show you more example of
noise reduction
so i'm trying to find it i put it in the
text based version of the tutorial it's
a very
poorly written function where
are you here we go
so i'm going to make a function here
called add
noise and what i'm going to do first is
i'm going to re-expand this out
probably condensing to 9 values is a
little silly
but so we're going to pull back to
64 here and
i'll go ahead and just retrain that
model i'll leave this information here
just because it's interesting
we'll come down here and we're going to
add a function
and it's just literally it's a function
that's just going to iterate through
every single pixel and in fact i'm using
random choice let me go ahead and import
random as well
uh and then randomly this is a five out
of a hundred percent chance
uh to it will randomly change that pixel
value essentially
so import random and um
so it's just going to add noise to an
image
so what we can do is we can say okay
there's our function
we will say noisy equals and we'll say x
test zero
whoops needs to be add noise x test
zero noise
and then now we can um let's just go
ahead and peel t
dot m show show or noisy image c
map equals gray so now we have a noisy
seven okay and what happens
with uh let's see if i can hopefully
copy and paste a quick ae
out here boop come down here paste and
rather than x test zero
it will be noisy um
okay and then we will do a plt dot m
show
not noisy ae out c-map
equals gray so what you see
is a pretty significantly
noise reduced variant right this is the
noisy seven
and then this is the kind of the the
seven that came out
of our auto encoder so what didn't we do
we did not
train an auto encoder to take noisy
examples of photos
and then so like you know you could
train a model
where you have your clean data set and
then you have your input
be you know this add noise a bunch of ad
noise examples
and then you could train a model to
remove noise but that's not actually
what we did
right we trained an auto encoder to just
take images and like
encode them into the meaning of that
image and in our case the auto encoder
again because
it's unsupervised machine learning has
just kind of figured out like
these this group of images goes together
and here's the generic version of that
group
right and we can even see that here like
this have this seven doesn't quite match
this
the original seven um
but it did a pretty good job removing
that noise because the autoencoder has
just simply learned
that the meaning of the value
or the meaning of um this input data is
actually somehow in this
in this number um again it's it's
unsupervised we don't know exactly how
it has done this
but i think hopefully up to this point
you have seen
um just how much auto encoders can
compress data
right we took 784 features and
compressed it down to nine
which was that nine out of seven nine
out of 784
uh basically one percent which is
absolutely nuts um i'm sure
that quite a few numbers condensed down
to this
um to that you know three by three or
nine values i'm sure
a few of them don't work or probably
even quite a few i wouldn't be surprised
if like
20 of the data sets illegible um
but you wouldn't condense it to one
percent but the idea is to just show you
that
you can use auto encoders to compress
data down
now the last thing i wanted to show with
auto encoders
is not only can you do noise reduction
and compression
the other thing you can do is just
change the overall
uh let's see this is for something else
pay no attention to my notes
you you can change the format of the
data so in this case
uh this i don't think i'm going to run
it i don't really see any benefit to
running it
uh maybe i'll put it in the text based
version of the tutorial if you want to
play with it but essentially what it's
doing is it's taking photos of cats and
dogs
and their color photos um i'm reshaping
all photos to be 64 by 64.
um we are doing the div by 255 but we're
keeping the
three channels right so the rgb channels
and then we're running it through
convolutional filters right and then
we're also doing max pooling in fact i
kind of want to run it uh
i think i'll let's see
maybe i'll run it okay um so
let me just uh python
three i think i'm running yeah i had the
the way i defined python is different on
like
windows this linux machine and that
linux machine so
it's super i always forget like which
one how do i call python and like which
version of python i want anyway
um we're running it for 15 epochs i
don't think i'm going to like
finish this training for you guys but
i'll let it at least start
because of really what i wanted to show
is right here so i wanted to show the uh
this model summary so this is what i was
talking about before
where um see how do i make it there we
go
um where essentially like what we're
doing here is we are
taking in 64 by 64 by three
which if we did the math on that uh i
think it's like 12 000 or something
64 times 64 times three
yeah 12 288 so if you were to just
flatten out a 64 by 64 rgb image
it would be 12 288 now why would you
ever want to flatten it out well for
example i was tinkering with the
um with trying to feed a sequence of
images
through a transformer model well the
transformer model
expects to take um an encoded input
right
a vector of values not a three-channel
image
so i was just curious can we condense
this down to a small enough value that
you could then
pass a sequence of images through a
specific transformer model
and um so i was just kind of playing
with that and essentially
what i what's going on here is you have
maybe by the time i get done yakking
we'll actually see some examples in
before some sort of stupid error but
anyway
you know you have your input which comes
in as a 64 by 64 by three we do some
convolutions to it but each time you do
a convolution
pay attention because like in this
example you're saying
64 and then the window is 3x3 and then
you can see what it what it winds up
generating in terms of values so each of
these
vectors that if at any point you were to
flatten would be
quite large right this in this case it's
64 by 64 by three if you flattened here
it's 64 by 64 by 64.
it'd be gigantic but then we do the
pooling and now we've pulled down
because the pooling layer i think was a
two by two yeah yeah
a two by two now we're down to 32 by 32
64.
still giant um but then we do another
convolution
uh then we're doing one more flatten
or did we do three pooling okay i think
this is only showing two i think no
my eyes are deceiving me we're doing
three anyway we pulled down to
um essentially flattened to 8192
but we're not done yet right then i'm
just throwing in a dense layer of 512.
just to do it right and that's the end
of the encoder so we can come over here
and see
the flatten and then the encoder output
is 512. so this is officially the
bottleneck
so the question was you know could we
condense down to 512 values
a vector of 512 rather than a vector of
12 thousand
288 right and we're getting the benefit
of using convolutional layers
um and again you could always simplify
this right you may not need to use rgb
images you might grayscale the images
first that
divides your data by three right out of
the gate so
um so anyway take note um but anyways
you essentially as you you know
convolutional
filters down down down down and then
you're also doing your
pooling you do the exact opposite on the
way
on the way back right you've got your
convolutionals but then you have up
sampling
so then you up sample but to the same
degree that you pooled
the only thing you have to be careful
about here is that there's no padding
going on in your pooling
so if there was there's prob there's
probably ways that you could
kind of get around it but but it becomes
very challenging to get it to up sample
all the way back to the exact
same input shape that you started with
so generally you're going to try to work
with a very specific input shape that
you can both
pull down and then up sample right back
up and again
literally you're using a layer that is
an up sampling layer
anyway uh did we never maybe it threw an
error
i guess we threw an air i wonder what
the problem is could internal error
fail to get convolutional algorithm
coding in it uh
why would that happen
um let's just run nvidia someone
i'm actually not really sure
uh so we've got the two gpus isn't this
one running on gpu one
yes so why
i'm not sure why that error you don't
have to see the output of it it's
literally just an image of a cat
[Music]
but it would be fun to show it to you
but yeah this one is full but it's
because we're
running uh here
i'm actually not sure why wouldn't that
um
i'm not sure why why i hit that error
way
anyway i'm not gonna waste all this time
and show it to you but just like i said
it's literally just a rgb picture of a
cat
but i can post the code uh and i'll put
it in the text based version of the
tutorial if you want to if you want to
tinker with it
um it's it's that it's a casper's dog
data set from uh from microsoft
anyway uh quite a long tutorial
um but there's just so much that you can
tinker with here
that uh we've really barely scratched
the surface because we didn't even
really talk like we showed the encoder
side of things
we didn't really show too much decoder
wise
and really you might be actually like in
many cases you're focused actually
primarily on the encoder
but there's going to be plenty of times
where you'd be focused on the decoder as
well
but the idea is always pretty much the
same it's to get a model to focus
very specifically on a challenge that
you have
uh and give it only one job to do rather
than you know the many jobs that a
neural network has to do
generically at the beginning of training
given a data set also i just think it's
freaking awesome that we can take i know
it's the eminence data set but
condensing it down to only nine values
and still producing the input data um
i think that's cool i think that's
really cool um so anyway
uh i think i'm going to stop it here i
think we're at like 50 minutes that's
quite a long tutorial
uh so anyways if you have questions uh
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below
also if you like uh getting into the
more nitty gritty with with neural
networks and tinkering
um i suggest you check out the neural
networks from scratch book i don't know
if you've ever heard of it
uh but yeah it's a book by uh daniel and
myself uh you can check that out at
nnfs.io
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you